[Music]
welcome back to science click today
special relativity let's imagine a
spaceship as well as a planet isolated
in the depths of the universe suppose
the spaceship is moving relative to the
planet in a fixed direction and with a
constant speed one of the first
fundamental properties of the universe
is that in this situation it is strictly
impossible to determine whether it is
the spaceship moving and the planet
being motionless or whether it is the
spaceship being motionless while the
planet is moving in the opposite
direction this is known as the principle
of relativity whichever point of view we
take as long as the movement occurs in a
straight line with a constant speed it
is equally valid to consider that it is
the spaceship or the planet that is
moving let's now imagine a passenger on
the spaceship who decides to throw a
ball forwards for him the ball is moving
forwards with a certain speed this speed
corresponds simply to the impulsion
which was given to the ball
but if we observe the same situation
from the point of view of the planet the
ball seems to be moving faster because
its speed of impulsion combines with the
speed of the spaceship itself the
strange thing is if we now try to do the
same experiment with light using a torch
light for example we see that whichever
point of view is taken the speed of
light remains the same regardless of
whether we look at it still or while
moving whether we shine it from a fixed
point or one that moves we will always
see light as moving with one same exact
speed
[Music]
we say that this speed of light is
invariant the speed of light is a
universal constant fundamental
underlying the very structure of our
universe in our daily lives the speed of
light is way too high to enable us to
see any effect this principle in only
the blink of an eye a light ray travels
the distance between Paris and New York
six times over nonetheless this subtle
property of light triggers drastic
changes on the way we see the world in
special relativity one fundamental idea
is that two events can occur
simultaneously for one person but at
different moments for someone else to
understand let's imagine the following
scenario the passenger in the spaceship
holds two torch lights one which he
points backwards and the other one
forwards his role will be to light the
two torch lights exactly at the same
time he will then look at which moment
the two light rays reached the edge of
the spaceship he begins by lighting the
two torch lights at the same time since
from his point of view the spaceship
stays motionless the light rays will
propagate both sides in the same way
thus they will reach the two ends of the
spaceship at the same moment for the
passenger the two events are
simultaneous both light rays reached the
two edges of the spaceship at the same
moment but let's now look at this same
situation as it is perceived by an
observer on the surface of the planet
we previously saw that the speed of
light is a constant therefore when the
two torch lights are turned on light
will spread with the same speed on both
sides but at the same time the spaceship
is moving forwards as such the light ray
sent towards the left will reach the
back of the spaceship before the light
ray on the right reaches the front from
this point of view the two events are
not simultaneous the light rays do not
reach the two sides of the spaceship at
the same time to explain this paradox
we must put to the side our intuitive
understanding of time in the previous
situation if the light ray on the Left
reaches the edge of the ship before the
light ray on the right this is in
reality because the rear of the
spaceship is slightly in the future
compared to the front of the ship which
is slightly in the past when it is noon
in the middle of the spaceship it might
already be 1 p.m. at the back of the
ship while it is only 11 a.m. at the
front of the ship from the perspective
of the passenger inside the ship the
clocks are perfectly synchronized for
him it is noon in all parts of the ship
it is the act of observing from a moving
point which D synchronizes the back in
the front of the ship one from the other
more generally when an object moves with
a very high speed compared to us we
observe that the front of the object
likes in time with respect to the rear
if we placed for example two people of
the same age we would observe from the
planet that the person at the front of
the ship is slightly younger while the
one at the back would be slightly older
one direct consequence of this
phenomenon is what we called length
contraction as we previously saw when it
is observed from the planet the rear of
the spaceship is slightly in the future
but since the spaceship is traveling in
time if the rear of the ship is in the
future it is also slightly ahead
compared to its movement equally the
front is slightly behind compared to the
movement of the spaceship the global
length of the ship therefore sees itself
contracted in the direction of its speed
at ordinary speeds this contraction is
minimal almost undetectable
for example a car moving at full speed
on a highway will only be contracted
around the length of an atom nucleus but
the closer we get to the speed of light
the more this contraction phenomenon
becomes important if our spaceship could
travel at 85% the speed of light its
length would be contracted by half and
at 99.5% the speed of light it's
observed length would only be a tenth of
its original length in this situation
seen from the planet the spaceship would
seem extremely contracted but from the
point of view of the passenger who is
inside it is not the spaceship that is
contracted but the planet as from his
point of view it is the planet which is
moving and not the spaceship
finally a third direct consequence of
the environment is what we called time
dilation to understand this let's
consider the following experiment the
passenger inside the spaceship will grab
a flashlight once again this time
pointing it towards the ceiling at a
given moment he will turn on the lights
and observe the time it takes for the
light rate to reach the ceiling of the
spaceship once again the problem changes
if we decide to observe the same
situation but from the planet for the
observer on the planet the spaceship and
the passenger inside are both moving
thus the beam of light will have to
travel not only the height of the
ceiling but will also have to travel
towards the right following the movement
of the spaceship from this point of view
the light ray must travel a greater
distance consequently just as it takes
more time to cross a road diagonally
rather than by its width it will take
light longer to reach the ceiling of the
spaceship for this observer watching the
situation from the planet the light ray
has thus taken more time to reach the
top of the spaceship in general this
observer will see the inside of the
spaceship evolving in slow motion if the
passenger on the ship decided to show a
clock from the planet we would see this
clock tick in slow motion
more generally when an object moves
extremely fast compared to us we see its
rear and front D synchronized its length
contracted and its evolution in slow
motion to sum up these phenomena let's
focus on the precise case of Mulan's
cosmic particles frequently penetrates
into the high atmosphere these cosmic
particles filled with energy will
progressively disintegrate until they
form elementary particles which we call
mu ons in a normal situation these
mulan's have an extremely short lifespan
they disappear after only a few
microseconds however when we try to
detect them from the surface of the
earth we see that a great number of
these moons still manage to reach the
ground this paradoxical situation can be
explained thanks to the phenomena which
we previously saw since the moon's
falling towards the ground can reach
extremely high speeds close to 99.5% the
speed of light we need to consider
length contraction as well as time
dilation
on the one hand let's begin by placing
ourselves from the point of view of a
moon for the moon it is the earth and in
particular the atmosphere which are
moving very quickly in its direction due
to length contraction the moon will thus
see a contracted atmosphere which is
much thinner in which it will therefore
have time to cross entirely before
disappearing on the other hand if we
place ourselves from the point of view
of an observer on earth it is the moon's
which are moving with a very high speed
due to time dilation we will see the
moon's as evolving in slow motion and as
such their lifespan will seem greater to
us once again moons will have the time
to reach the ground well before they
disintegrate to conclude the simple fact
that the speed of light is constant
triggers some major consequences on the
way we see the world when an object is
moving compared to us in a straight line
and with a very high speed we see it
evolving in slow motion while it also
seems contracted in the direction of the
movement this understanding of the
relativity of time and space depending
on the movement of objects is what we
call special relativity it teaches us
that time and space are not absolute
that two observers can potentially
perceive them differently it also
triggers a great number of effects such
as the fact that is absolutely
impossible to go beyond the speed of
light since to only reach this speed
would require an infinite amount of
energy
however this type of relativity is
labeled as special because it only
applies in very simple cases mostly for
movements that occur in a straight line
with a constant speed length contraction
and time dilation are not adequate to
describe other types of movement for
example changes in direction
accelerations slowdowns or even
rotations to do this it will be
necessary to adopt a much more thorough
theory which enables us to account for
gravitational pull on the basis of a
distorted geometry of space and time
this is the theory of general relativity
[Music]
you
[Music]